ايرانية الصنع من طراز شاهد مائة
وست وثلاثين الملقبة بالكاميكاز
ودعواته لحل البرلمان. فاين
سيرسو العراق ابلغت المملكة
مكتملة الصلاحيات. هذا التيار
الصدري في رفض الوضع الحالي
بلدا نوويا. المفتش العام للقوات
المسلحة المغربية فاروق بالخير
باريس على اطفاء انوار البرج من
الحادية عشرة مساء. ايران تظهر
وستة وثلاثون الف برميل يوميا.
كما انها ستبقي زيادة الانتاج
اوكرانيا وتايوان. فماذا يخبئون
لنا تحت طاولة هذا الاجتماع?
يغرق في الظلام بعد اطفاء انواره
بسبب الطاقة في فرنسا التي اجبرت
في اوكرانيا اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني انه اسقط مسيرة
والتي اعلنت عن توصل ارمينيا
واذربيجان الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق
الاحداث والتطورات. وكان بوتين
يقول وداعا للرومانسي. برج ايفل
عشر مليون وواحد وخمسين الف
برميل يوميا بزيادة قدرها مائتان
الاسعار ترتفع بنسبة خمسمائة في
المائة في مقاهي بريطانيا ما
ستسهم الحرب الجديدة في تخفيف
الضغط الروسي على اوكرانيا?
التركي على سيادة اليونان. ما كل
هذه الثقة المفرطة يا ماكرون اذا
حذرت كوريا الجنوبية بان ردها
سيكون ساحقا ان استخدمت اسلحة
اليونانيان المنطقة. وفور ما
ارسل خفر السواحل التركي لمراقبة
فرنسا تزعج انقرة. وصفتها تركيا
بالجار المؤذي. نعم يا سادة
الاذربيجاني جوان بيراموف قائلا
يجب على ارمينيا ان تكف عن
اذربيجان. هذا الموقف كان متوقعا
اذ تمتلك تركيا تاريخا من
للجانبين الارميني والاذربيجاني
ضرورة وقف القتال وبدء محادثات
بينما الجيش الاوكراني يستمر في
تقدمه والجيش الروسي يتموضع
جاراباخ المتنازع عليه فيما
بينهما مواقف الدولية تباينت بين
بالقرب من كوبيانسك داخل اقليم
خركيف شرق اوكرانيا. اعلن
المعتقل كان لديه امكانية الوصول
الى وثائق تقنية اكثر سرية.
الحرب الثانية بينهما في خريف
الفين وعشرين حول جيب ماجوري
استفزازاتها وان تركز على
مفاوضات السلام والتعاون مع
التركي مولود جاويش اوغلو بعد
اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره
اذربيجان على استعادة اجزاء
كبيرة من الاراضي. برأيكم هل
تركيا تتهم اليونان باستهداف
سفينة بالنيران قبالة سواحلها
المتهم قام اثناء توليه منصبه
بتصوير اجزاء من رسومات معدات
شي جين بينغ والتركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في اوزباكستان بشأن
اشتباكات حدودية واسعة النطاق
اسفرت عن مقتل تسعة واربعين
لتعلن عن اجتماع عاجل مع تركيا
والصين. فماذا يخبئ هذا الاجتماع
اثار موجة غضب بين البريطانيين.
في العراق رفض رئيس ائتلاف دولة
هذه ما سيؤثر على اسعار النفط
حسب الخبراء. روسيا تعمل بصمت
الاستخبارات العسكرية ولكن قد
يكون هذا بنظر الروس الاخطر
باريس. اكد ماكرون لرئيس وزراء
اليونان عن دعم بلاده الواضح
والحازم له في مواجهة اي تهديد
من الجانب التركي. واضاف ان
داعية للسلام ومحذرة لاحد
الاطراف. نبدأ بالخارجية الروسية
فرنسا تدعم اليونان في جميع
مواقفها وترفض تطاول الجانب
الاليزيه. الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون وزوجته بريجيت
القانون نوري المالكي فكرة اجراء
انتخابات قبل تشكيل حكومة جديدة
العربية السعودية اوبك انها رفعت
انتاجها في اغسطس الماضي الى احد
نحن بانتظار ردك يا حفيد عثمان.
الحرب القديمة تشتعل. في ذروة
مما جعلها تحتج رسميا ضدها وتفتح
تحقيقا بعد ان غادر الزورقان
سلام. اما الموقف التركي فقد جاء
محذرا اذ اكد وزير الخارجية
وغيرها تدخل على الخط حرب جديدة
قديمة بين اذربيجان وارمينيا.
العلاقات مع اذربيجان اذ دعمت
انقرة باكو في صراع عام الفين
يجري زيارة رسمية هي الاولى الى
كيان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي.
نووية ضدها وذلك ردا على اعلان
جارتها الشمالية نفسها مؤخرا
عسكريا ارمينيا في احدث تصعيد
للعنف بين الدولتين منذ ان انتهت
الصراعات العالمية بين روسيا
وامريكا واوكرانيا وتايوان
الى مواطن اوكراني يعمل في مصنع
اوديسا للطيران. واوضح الجهاز ان
العملية العسكرية الروسية في
اوكرانيا فورا ليصرح بعدها بشكل
القادمة? خيانة استراتيجية. لقد
تم اعتقال الكثير منهم من قبل
اعتقال مدير رقابة الجودة في
مصنع طائرات بمقاطعة موسكو بتهمة
قديروف وبعد انتقاداته اللاذعة
التي اطلقها تجاه القادة الروس
تايمز الاستخبارات الامريكية
ساعدت باعداد هجوم للقوات
ذلك الوضع المتعلق باعادة
التموضع قرب خركيف. نيويورك
الخيانة العظمى. وقد صرح جهاز
امن الدولة الروسي في بيان له ان
ماكرون وفي الجهة الاخرى رئيس
الوزراء اليوناني كرياكوس
الكرملين ان الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين سيجري محادثات مع الصيني
السفينة التجارية التي هاجمتها
اليونان. ياتي الرد سريعا من قصر
ميتسوتاكيس وزوجته ماريفا
غرابوفسكي بقصر الاليزيه في
فما هي تلك الشروط؟ نعم هي غير
معلنة حتى هذه اللحظة. ليأتي
باوكرانيا واضاف لم يكن بمقدورنا
استعادة مناطق في اوكرانيا من
روسيا لا ترى اي فرصة لاجراء
محادثات سلام. نعم هذا هو حصاد
بلاده تسعى لانهاء ما اسماه
الاحتلال الروسي في كل المناطق
الجيش الاوكراني يعلن عن استعادة
عشرين بلدة في يوم واحد في جنوبي
ان ان الامريكية الرئيس
الاوكراني الزلنيسكي قال ان
هنا الجانب الاوكراني يضع شروطا
للعودة الى المفاوضات مع روسيا.
اليوم الذي استطعنا ان نجمع لكم
من ساحة الحروب العسكرية
عمليتها العسكرية الخاصة في
اوكرانيا. واشار ديسكوف الى ان
الروسية مقتل اكثر من ثلاثمائة
جندي اوكراني على محور نيكولاي
النار بدورها وزارة الخارجية
الامريكية انتوني بلينكين اكد
الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون وفي اتصال
هاتفي حث على ضرورة انهاء
الرد من المتحدث باسم الكريملين
ديمتري بسكوف روسيا ستحقق اهداف
بينهم. نعم هنا جهاز امن الدولة
الفيدرالي في روسيا يعلن عن
الطيران العسكري باستخدام هاتفه
المحمول ونقل المعلومات كاملة
هجوم مضاد على جبهتين لاستعادة
الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها روسيا
عسكريون. روسيا تهدف الى ضرب
البنية التحتية للجيش الاوكراني.
مفاجأة للقوات الروسية. وزارة
الدفاع الروسية ترد الانسحاب من
عشرين وزودتها بطائرات برقدار
التي اثبتت جدارته وساعدت
الروسي وبعدها بساعات استيقظ
العالم على هول فاجعة عسكرية.
صرح بان بوتين يعلم بمجريات
العملية العسكرية كافة بما في
مصورة لقصف روسي متعدد بالصواريخ
والمدافع على اهداف عسكرية
والكلامية وبكل حيادية. فماذا
سيحدث برأيكم في الساعات
اليوم تترك معدات عسكرية قديمة
وشبه تالفة. الانتصارات تتوالى
بشكل متسارع ومرعب البلدات
والمناطق التي تم السيطرة عليها
رسمي قائلا سنواصل دعم كييف
عسكريا واقتصاديا. وهنا رمضان
دون الدعم الامريكي. ديمتري
بيسكوف المتحدث باسم الكريملين
وقد تستخدم استراتيجية قتالية
مختلفة. وفي مقابلة مع شبكة سي
الدوما الروسي وعبر منشور في
قناة. واشنطن تخطئ بظنها ان
جوية على القوات في مقاطعة خركيف
وكوبيانسك وازيوم واسفرت عن مقتل
الاوكرانية في ضواحي خركيف.
ليأتي الرد الساخن من رئيس مجلس
نعم. روسيا تعلن اعترافها
بجمهوريتي دوندسك والوجانسك
ازيوم يهدف الى تعزيز القوات
الروسية في دونيتسك. مراقبون
بوليتكو الامريكية نقلا عن
مسؤولين اوكران قالت ان كييف
اوكرانية واظهرت الصور مشاهد
جوية لتدمير اهداف اوكرانية وفق
في شرق اوكرانيا. الكريملين يرد.
بوتين مطلع على الوضع في خركيف.
بعدها بوتين غزوه لاوكرانيا.
احداث اليوم اشبه بالامس. روسيا
لتصرخ بعدها صافرات الانذار في
كييب. نعم الاحداث تتسارع ليعلن
الحرب لن تمسها في النهاية. وذلك
حسب تعبيره وكالة الكرملين
مقصلة الصدر وسندان المالكي.
دخان الحرب لا يتوقف. عندما
تراجع المفوضية الاوروبية عن فرض
تحديد سقف لسعر الغاز الروسي
ابلغت البنتاجون ومسؤولين
عسكريين غربيين مسبقا بخططها لشن
نحو مائتين وخمسين عسكري
اوكراني. كما اكدت الدفاع
ليظهر هنا قائلا الحرب
الاقتصادية ضدنا فشلت. فماذا عن
جريفيروب واصابة ما يصل الى الف
عسكري منهم خلال يوم واحد. وهنا
واحدة. كونك ستسارع في استنزاف
رصيد كبريائك. اظهرت وثائق مسربة
الحرب العسكرية يا حفيد ستالين
الا تتذكرون عندما اعلنت روسيا
البلاد. الاستخبارات البريطانية
الهجوم الاوكراني في غركيف كان
من حفيد عثمان. وحرب دولية جديدة
تشتعل بين هاتين الدولتين فمن
الصداع. يا الهي ما الذي يحدث?
دعونا ننقل لكم اخر التطورات
اوكرانيا. والسعودية تقول كلمتها
الاخيرة لاوروبا والعراق بين
الميدانية وكما قلتها لكم سابقا.
سننقلها مطلقة فلتربط احزمة
بيان الوزارة. ومرة اخرى. وزارة
الدفاع الروسية تعلن شن ضربات
انسحابها من الحدود الاوكرانية
وانها لن تغزو اوكرانيا وانها
المجنون متوعدة برد عسكري.
والكاميكاز الايراني تظهر في
والعملية مستمرة حتى تحقيق
اهدافها. اسمعت يا قديروف صحيفة
سينفذه بوتين؟ بينما تركيا تتلقى
صفعة فرنسية موجعة لتنتظر الرد
من قبل الجيش الاوكراني ينسحب
منها المدنيون والعسكريون في ان
واحد هنا المدينة شبه خالية. ما
الذي يخطط له بوتين? رأسي يصيبه
الامان لننطلق. هنا البداية نشرت
وزارة الدفاع الروسية مشاهد
ووثائق روسية مسربة تزعج امريكا
بينما الرئيس الاوكراني يبشر
واشنطن وبمكالمة هاتفية ماكرون
يطلب من بوتين هذا الطلب فهل
تشتعل الحروب العسكرية والنفسية
من الصعب ان تعود للخلف خطوة
كانت مجرد مناورات عسكرية فقط?
الجميع في ذلك اليوم بلعت طعم
سيطفئها؟ وبريطانيا تختنق
اقتصاديا وكوريا الجنوبية تحذر
عسكريا? فلمن ستكون الغلبة?
بشكل عاجل بينما الاستخبارات
الروسية تقبض على فريسة ثمينة
ان كان الطريق على ما يرام فاعلم
انك في كمين. مقولة عسكرية شهيرة
قد تلخص الاحداث الحالية. بوتين
واردوغان والرئيس الصيني يجتمعون